bonjour bastien mouly merci d'être avec
nous en direct dans la matinale
le ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
valérie vidal a donc demandé
il y a un peu moins d'une semaine cette
enquête
qu'est-ce que ça illustre déjà au sein
même de la majorité
il ya eu une césure alors qu'on est en
plein débat sur le projet de loi sur le
séparatisme notamment celui de l'islam
radical
certains macro nist ont estimé que la
question de l'islamo gauchisme n'était
pas prioritaire même emmanuel macron n'a
pas souhaité soutenir frédéric vidal et
puis il y as cnrs qui a rappelé dans un
communiqué que le terme d'
islamo-gauchiste mme ne correspondaient
à aucune réalité scientifique ce qui est
assez étonnant puisque l'un des
directeurs de recherche du cnrs pierre
andré taguieff est peut-être le premier
en france à avoir alerté dans ses
travaux sur l'islamo gauchisme dans la
société
c'était au début des années 2000 et la
position officielle du cnrs peut étonner
puisqu'il y à des recherches sur le des
colonialismes sur l'islamophobie sur le
racisme d'état en france et tout ce qui
se rapporte aux luttes intersectionnelle
et en même temps pour le cnrs l'islamo
gauchisme serait quant à lui seulement
un slogan politique et non une réalité
scientifique
ouais en tout cas frédéric vidal se
retrouve un peu esseulé non dans la
majorité la classe politique c'est le
cas pas totalement car au sein des
macros nist il y en a qui s'inquiètent
de ce militantisme dans les universités
comme le ministre jean michel blanquer
où la députée aurore bergé
frédéric vidal est aussi soutenu par des
élus de l'opposition comme au sein de
rassemblement national ou de la droite
dite modérée
on peut penser aux députés les
républicains tendance gaulliste julien
daire rappelons qu'il avait proposées en
novembre avec son collègue de la droite
damien abad que l'assemblée nationale en
sur l'islamo gauchisme et ce qu'on
appelle la cancel culture dans les
milieux universitaires
il avait reçu une fin de non recevoir
après les propos de frédéric vidal
dernièrement les deux députés n'ont
d'ailleurs relancé leur demande en
écrivant il y a quelques jours au
parlement à jean castex et à emmanuel
macron pour qu'une mission d'information
parlementaire
ce bel et bien créé afin d'évaluer ces
dérives idéologiques et qu'en est-il
bastien du du monde universitaire lui
ils refusent de devoir l'islamo
gauchisme on peut penser vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure à ses 600 universitaire
qui à travers une tribune veulent le
départ de frédéric vidal mais il ne faut
pas croire que le monde universitaire
soit unanime sur le sujet environ 80
chercheurs ont créé par exemple
l'observatoire du des colonialismes pour
dénoncer les idéologies identitaire dont
font partie l'islamo gauchisme
l'indigénisme où les théories des
colonials tout cela s'entrecroisent pour
des mouvements militants qui assigne
chaque personne à des identités de race
ou de religion
le professeur de droit public anne marie
le pourhiet nous expliquait d'ailleurs
que le terrain de jeu préféré de ces dix
identitaire était les sciences molles
comme la sociologie ou la science
politique
elle nous donnait notamment l'exemple de
jeunes doctorants qui devenait qui
devait se plier à cette théorie pour
espérer avoir un poste dans une forme de
tribalisme idéologique pour reprendre
ces trêves ces termes
merci beaucoup bastien gouly pour toutes
ces explications et on l'article est
bien sûr un signe de votre main et bien
sûr à retrouver sur le site rtl pointé v
merci beaucoup